[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and a whole
host of new leaks have just hit the web
in regards to spider-man far from home
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the recently released spoilers as
well as giving my thoughts on them this
is of course full spoilers ahead so if
you don't want anything about the movie
runed that I highly recommend that you
turn off now you should always take
leaks like this with a pinch of salt but
it massively lines up with other
spoilers that have been released so far
so it seems to make a lot of sense
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video I
hope you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my breakdown of
spider-man bar from home okay so the
leaks have been posted to the Marvel
Studios spoilers subreddit from user
agnostic mannitol who apparently saw the
movie at the premiere screening I've
added in some leaks from other sources
to flesh out the story a bit as the
users list is mainly bullet points with
the first act from the trailers missing
but if you want to read the thread I'll
link it in the description below so you
can go through the whole thing after
this video
apparently the movie opens in the wake
of Tony Stark's death at the end of
endgame and similar to homecoming the
film has a montage of the heroes that
was put together by Peter Parker this
video is sort of referential to the
prior movie but instead of the
enthusiastic Parker that we saw in Civil
War it's very downtrodden and sad flying
home from the funeral Peter is told by
happy that Tony would have wanted him to
become his successor however Peter
doesn't want the responsibility and
decides to go on vacation with a school
to Europe he doesn't pack his suit
however later in the film we discover
that Aunt May packed it into his luggage
it's revealed that a small handful of
Peter's classmates and teachers were
snatched while the others have aged up
five years and this has paid lip-service
by the fact that one of the students who
was apparently very ugly is now on
their flights are some of the first out
after the destabilization of society in
endgame and the class are touring
through Europe as a way to get everyone
settled back into education without the
stress this is when Nick Fury catches up
with Peter recruits him and he meets
Mysterio who is apparently from another
world that was destroyed by the
elementals they've come to earth and are
now apparently trying to ravage the
planet though this becomes an earth
later on in the movie Mysterio tries to
become Peters new mentor and attempts to
manipulate him by using Tony Stark and
Iron Man visions this is because he
wants Peter to quit being spider-man so
that he can continue being praised as a
hero in the film it's revealed that
Mysterio is not actually from the
multiverse and has been lying the entire
time Mysterio uses projections drone
equipment and other things to make the
elementals he used to work for Tony
Stark but was fired and when stark
disappeared in infinity war he stole
some tech now that Tony is dead he
finally sees this as an opportunity to
rise up and take his place as a hero
without any real questions as the world
is still recovering from endgame peter
has introduced the new high tech that
belonged to Iron Man and in the movie he
gets help from happy and quote unquote
fury which I'll get into later and
contrary to other leaks and rumors there
is no Tony Stark AI in Peters suit or in
his high-tech lab however in the lab
Peter makes a new black and red suit by
combining the red and blue one with the
stealth suit he thinks the stealth suits
too clunky and the scene sort of a fun
montage of him gobbling it together as
Peter takes Mysterio on and Ned and MJ
also brought into the fight with MJ
smashing a lot of the drones with a mace
this is where the MJ Funko pop comes
into play and explains why the character
had this weapon in the release the movie
ends with Michelle and Peter officially
dating however it's not really a happy
ending for the webhead Mysterio
apparently dies at the end and releases
an edited version of a tape that shows
not only that Spiderman carried
the elemental attacks but also that he
is in fact Peter Parker we don't get to
see the aftermath of this reveal and it
apparently cuts very suddenly just like
Aunt May's reaction in the first film
but this identity reveal is of course
very very big news fans of the comic
book will know that this is very in line
with the comic series civil war in which
Peter revealed his identity on TV and he
had to deal with the consequences of it
the first post-credit scene shows more
of the Mysterio tape and then we pull
out to see none other than Jay jonah
Jameson watching it the character is
once again played by JK Simmons and it's
an awesome awesome Easter Egg now
contrary to other reporting leaks the
final post-credit scene doesn't have the
chameleon scorpion vulture shocker or
Mysterio and most notably there is no
Norman Osborn early reports said that
he'd bought Avengers Tower and changed
it into Oscorp however this is
apparently wrong and the final post
credit scene reportedly shows Nick Fury
and Maria hill transformed into Talos
and another scroll they were asked to
take fury in Hills place on earth while
the real ones were on holiday and this
is why fury gets mad at Peter earlier in
the film for not mentioning character
Marvel that ends the film and honestly
it sounds pretty sick if this is what
gets put on the big screen then I'll be
really happy with how the films turned
out I think the identity reveal whilst
big is nothing that Marvel haven't had
to deal with before and pretty much all
of the heroes in the universe are known
by their public names it of course also
ties back to the ending of the original
Iron Man and if this is the direction
that they wish to take on the character
then I'm definitely definitely on board
now again this should all be taken with
a pinch of salt but there's a lot of
leaks floating around that confirm the
same thing from numerous accounts so it
seems likely that this is the case
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on these leaks and if you think they'll
happen or not if you've heard something
else that make sure you leave it in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my full breakdown of the
entire Jay jonah Jameson post-credit
scene which will be linked at the end we
go over every detail and discuss
Mysterio's motives more in depth so it's
definitely worth watching if you want to
know more I'll leave that linked at the
end so make sure you give it a click
after this this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for take the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and let's see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]